Manifest is just wrapped up it's
midseason finale and it still feels like
there's a lot to uncover from the show
whether it's the mysterious villains
what happened to the passengers and more
every episode adds something to the
enigma throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything you need to
know about the show's midseason finale
as well as what I think the events will
lead to there will be heavy spoilers so
if you haven't watched the latest
episode and I suggest that you turn off
now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to you throughout season 1 we
learned of the shadowy organization that
kidnapped the passengers of flight 88 in
the mid-season finale of manifest Ben
Mikayla and Vance discovered the
location of the missing passengers due
to one of Cal's visions the group
discovered the passengers tied up and
being experimented on and managed to
free them before they are neutralized by
the scientists whilst the facility was
destroyed during an explosion the group
still managed to capture some of the
scientists and hopefully they and the
freed passengers can offer some
explanation the cost of the search was
high however and Vance was apparently
killed during it personally I think this
is a ruse by the character and show to
fool us into thinking that the character
is deceased
Vance will now likely be in the
crosshairs due to his involvement with
the investigation so it makes sense for
him to use this as an opportunity to go
into hiding another possibility is that
Vance has been captured by unified
dynamic systems and that they are now
holding him hostage what we do learn
from season 1 is that company tied to
unify dynamic systems is behind the
events of the show we learned that the
person leading the company is named the
major and he could prove to be season
one's big bad villain with his mission
at the singularity project the major
supersedes Belsen but that doesn't mean
that the latter doesn't have a couple of
tricks up his sleeve we learn that
belton has a spy working for him named
autumn who was allowed to escape so that
she could gain Ben's trust this will
likely prove to be the show's wildcard
in the second part of the season and I
can't wait to see how this pans out what
the singularity project entails is still
yet
fully answered but it's clear that the
passengers have been gifted with certain
abilities Carl seems to be able to
predict the future while Spain has the
ability to be guided by a spiritual
force whether these abilities will grow
is unclear but I assume that they will I
can't wait to see what powers manifest
excuse the pun in the second part of the
season so what are your thoughts on
manifest are you enjoying the show and
what you expect to see in the second
part of season 1 comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and check out my
breakdown of this week's other big
mid-season finale The Walking Dead which
will be linked at the end of this video
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]